AND NATO TROOPS TO EVENTUALLY
LEAVE THE WAR TORN COUNTRY AFTER
NEARLY TWO DECADES OF FIGHTING.
AFTER EIGHT YEARS SERVING AS AN
INTERPRETER FOR THE U.S.
MILITARY AND AFGHANISTAN, AND
BEING CREDITED WITH SAVING THE
LIVES OF AT LEAST FIVE SOLDIERS,
OFFICIALLY BECOMING AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN SHARES HIS
STORY.
>> TODAY I BECAME A U.S.
CITIZEN.
>> HE WORKED FOR YEARS AS A
COMBAT TRANSLATOR ALONGSIDE THE
82ND AIRBORNE FACING THREATS
FROM THE TALIBAN FOR WORKING
WITH U.S. TROOPS.
HE ARRIVED IN THE U.S. SEVEN
YEARS AGO TODAY HE AND HIS
FAMILY WERE REWARDED FOR HIS
DUTY.
HE HAS TWO CHILDREN BECAME U.S.
CITIZENS.
ACTING DHS SECRETARY
KEN CUCCINELLI OVERSAW THE
CEREMONY.
>> DURING HIS SERVICE HE SAVED
THE LIVES OF FIVE AMERICAN
SOLDIERS.
>> ONE WAS THIS AMERICAN
SOLDIER.
>> THERE WERE TWO TALIBAN BEHIND
HIM TO KILL HIM AND I SHOT AT
THE TALIBAN.
>> 18,000 AFGHANS WHO WORKED FOR
THE U.S. MILITARY ARE AWAITING
VISAS.
DESPITE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, THEY
HAVE HAD TO LOBBY CONGRESS ON
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO HONOR
THE SPECIAL IMMIGRATION PROGRAM
THAT AUTHORIZES 4,000 VISAS A
YEAR FOR THOSE WHO HELPED THE
U.S. MILITARY.
A RECENT STATE DEPARTMENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
SUGGESTED THAT THE BACKLOG HAS
BEEN MADE WORSE BECAUSE THERE’S
ONLY ONE PERSON AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OVERSEEING THE
PROGRAM.
>> IT TOOK THREE YEARS TO GET MY
VISA.
THIS PROCESS IS GETTING MUCH
LONGER.
MOST OF THEM GOT KILLED BY
TALIBAN WAITING FOR IT.
>> FOX NEWS FIRST REPORTED TWO
YEARS AGO ON NO ONE LEFT BEHIND.
THE VETERANS NONPROFIT THAT
HELPS BRING AFGHAN COMBAT
TRANSLATORS WHO RISKED THEIR
LIVES TO THE U.S. AND SUPPORTS
THEM WITH DONATIONS AS THEY
RESTART THEIR LIVES.
>> MY KIDS WERE VERY EXCITED
LAST NIGHT BEFORE THEY GO TO
SLEEP.
THEY ASKED ME THAT IF WE WAKE UP
TOMORROW MORNING, WE WOULD BE A
U.S. CITIZEN.
I SAID YES, YOU SHOULD BE A U.S.
CITIZEN TOMORROW.
>> HE IS STILL SUPPORTING THE
U.S. MILITARY WORKING FOR A
DEFENSE CONTRACTOR WHO PROVIDES